so we've already looked at the current
factions of the Republican Party the pro
and the anti-trump Republicans the
pro-trump Republicans are now split into
sort of the Q Wing which are people that
support people like Marjorie Taylor
green and Matt Gates and then you've got
the sort of pro-trump but anti-q wing of
the modern Republican party these are
people that generally like Trump but
they don't like all of these problematic
hangers on that have surfaced uh
Republican senator Lindsey Graham seems
to think that none of these factions
really matter insofar as the Republican
Party absolutely needs Donald Trump is
dependent on Donald Trump's involvement
in their party and they simply cannot
move forward as a viable political party
without Donald Trump which is a very
strong statement to make but there's a
reason we call Lindsey Graham flimsy
Lindsay and comparing his latest
statements over the weekend with those
in the past will tell us a lot about
that now the first question is whether
Lindsey Graham is in some sense correct
in what he is now saying whether or not
he believes it right is he simply saying
this because he's in Trump's good graces
and Trump's involvement in Republican
politics is good for Lindsay there are
all sorts of reasons he might be saying
this he may mean it he may not but let's
look at what Lindsey Graham had to say
over the weekend just say to my
Republican colleagues can we move
forward uh without president Trump the
answer is no I've always liked Liz
Cheney but she's made a determination
that the Republican party can't can't
grow with President Trump I've
determined we can't grow without him all
of these people like Herschel Walker and
all the people you just named are
attracted to the Trump Republican party
economic populism America First agenda
if you don't get that as a republican
you're making the biggest mistake in the
history of the Republican party this is
actually really interesting because
Lindsay is not wrong that people like
Herschel Walker and a ton of those that
we saw being interviewed or were going
to see being interviewed at this event
in Florida over the weekend saying
listen I saw it on TV Trump won all of
this stuff it is 100 true that a lot of
these people never paid attention to
American politics before Donald Trump it
is true that it was Trump's populist
rhetoric and his America First agenda
that attracted them to Donald Trump the
Practical issue though is what effect
that actually had because Trump's
populist rhetoric
never materialized into policy all the
stuff Trump ran on either didn't happen
or it was perverted into some crony
handout like PPP as an example Trump's
America First agenda ended up alienating
much of the western world who were our
long-term allies and case in point
Republican trumpism led to Republicans
losing the House of Representatives in
2018
losing the senate in 2020 losing the
White House in 2020. now the entire
analysis is predicated on Lindsay is now
being sincere
I don't know if he is because remember
that on the evening of January 6th in
the midst of the Trump riots Lindsey
Graham seemed to say on the floor of the
Senate
this is too much I'm out the direction
of trumpism uh is what led people to
Riot on January 6th and he can't be a
part of it remember when Lindsay said
this uh Trump and I we've had a hell of
a journey
I hate it being this way oh my God I
hate it from my point of view he's been
a consequential president but today
first thing you'll see
all I can say
is uh count me out enough is enough
I've tried to be helpful
but when this Wisconsin Supreme Court
ruled four to three that they didn't
violate the Supreme the constitution of
Wisconsin I agree with the three but I
accept the four if Al Gore could accept
5-4 he's not president I can accept
Wisconsin 4-3
Pennsylvania it went to the second
circuit so much for all the judges being
in Trump's pocket
they said no you're wrong I accept the
Pennsylvania second circuit that Trump's
lawsuit wasn't wasn't right Georgia they
said the Secretary of State took the law
in his own hands he changed the election
laws unlawfully
a federal judge said no I accept the
federal judge even though I don't agree
with it
fraud they said there's 66 000 people in
Georgia under 18 voted how many people
believe that
I asked give me 10 and had one
they said 8 000 felons in prison and
Arizona voted give me ten hadn't got
what
does that say there's there's problems
in every election
I don't buy this enough's enough
we got to end it so the question of
course is which Lindsey Graham is the
sincere one and if he's posturing and
trying to get back in Trump's good
graces now that it seems Trump does want
to stay involved in Republican Party
politics at least through 2022 maybe
depending on how that goes into 2024 if
Lindsay is just saying what he thinks
Trump wants to hear is it even worth it
for the Republican party to listen to
Lindsey Graham Trump may be great for
Lindsay so Lindsay can have the
president on speed dial get rides on the
presidential helicopter and on Air Force
One all of that stuff but just because
it's good and fun and exciting for
Lindsey Graham to be friends with the
president doesn't mean it's actually
good for the Republican party and again
if you want another example of why they
call this guy flimsy Lindsay just waving
in the wind going with whatever
Direction it's blowing politically this
is the same Lindsay gram early in the
2016 primary
denouncing Donald Trump and accurately
so remember this what is your reaction
to hearing what Donald Trump says I
discussed it
well I want to talk to the Trump
supporters for a minute I don't know who
you are and I don't know why you like
this guy I think what you like about him
he appears to be strong when the rest of
us are weak he's a very successful
businessman he's going to make
everything great he's going to take all
the problems of the world and put him in
a box and make your life better that's
what he's selling here's what you're
buying he's a race-baiting xenophobic
religious bigot
he doesn't represent my party he doesn't
represent the values that the men and
women who wear the uniform are fighting
for so the point is I don't trust
Lindsey Graham as far as I can throw him
but it doesn't matter since I'm not
trying to help the Republican party I
don't need to figure out whether I need
to be listening to Lindsey Graham or not
for me it's just a question of will the
Republican Party fall for this the
Republican party on the other hand does
have to figure out their framework and
their structure heading into 2022 and
that race starts in six months
understand that there's not an unlimited
amount of time for the Republican party
to decide which direction are we going
to go and are we going the uh anti-trump
side which is one side are we going
pro-trump anti-q
or are we going full in Q Marjorie
Taylor green Matt Gates these types of
people it's down to about six months for
them to figure it out one of our
sponsors is curiositystream letting my
audience try it free for an entire month
curiositystream is a streaming service
offering thousands of documentaries from
some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals and
curiosity stream is just like the
Netflix for documentaries it's perfect
for anybody who loves politics History
Science just documentaries in general
I've been watching a ton of curiosity
stream I can watch on my TV my phone my
tablet and one of the first things I
noticed about curiositystream is that
these are high quality documentaries not
the cheap documentaries on many other
streaming services I've noticed
curiositystream has the biggest and
newest titles from the most respected
documentary filmmakers my favorite so
far has been what is reality by David
Eagleman I've read his books and the
documentary is fantastic curiosity
stream is just 299 month or 1999 for a
whole year but my audience can try it
free for a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
promo code Pacman